Bonsoir à tous.
Rare compromis aux États-Unis
entre deux partis qu'on estimait
condamnés à l'immobilisme
sur la question des armes à feu.
Un groupe de sénateurs;
10 Républicains et 10
Démocrates, ont conclu
un accord pour en resserrer
le contrôle.
Le projet de réforme
qui comprend également un volet
sur la santé mentale et
la sécurité dans les écoles,
thèmes chers aux républicains,
devra maintenant obtenir l'aval
du Sénat.
Mais cette avancée, Azeb,
est somme toute assez timide.
- Oui Claudine, c'est modeste
mais ici on parle carrément de
miracle pour que les démocrates
et les républicains arrivent à
s'entendre sur un petit bout de
texte, ce pays est polarisé. Ils
sont entendus sur deux choses
importantes : on retire les
armes dangereuses, on vérifie
les antécédents judiciaires. Là-
dessus 10 sénateurs républicains
et démocrates sont entendus. On
est loin de l'interdiction de
fusil semi-automatique de
- de 21 ans et déchargea à
pleine capacité. On est loin de
tout ça, mais quand même c'est
un pas en avant. Joe Biden a dit
que c'était significatif.
- Mais Azeb, on est très loin
des réformes réclamées par la
population, on l'a vu hier avec
toutes les manifestations
partout au pays?
- Oui il y a eu beaucoup de
familles, des enfants, des pères
de famille qui craigne le pire
et qui ont été témoin de la
tuerie à Uvalde. C'est la même
chose pour la tuerie à Buffalo,
les gens ne se sentent pas du
tout protégé. 80 % de la
population est en faveur d'une
vérification d'antécédents
judiciaires et psychologiques,
72 % sont pour le drapeau rouge
si une personne est dangereuse,
62 % sont pour l'interdiction
des armes semi-automatiques.
Donc, la population veut
vraiment un changement et ça ne
s'est pas traduit encore aux
lois au congrès. Écoutant le
sénateur qui dit qu'il fait
l'exception et qu'il est
ostracisme de la part des
républicains.